this is a production of cornell
university
uh thank you very much for inviting me
uh
yeah my name is hendrik joyman a hard
thing to say
i'm
working at the swedish university
culture i will i will show you some
picture from that but
i just want to say that i'm not a native
english speaker so bear in mind that
sometimes i get quiet
and then i go through a crisis in my
head to find the right words
and if i say penis i mean pinus
and we talk about pine trees nothing
else
so i pronounce probably things a little
bit different so i just want to make
sure everybody on the same page okay
so just an introduction sweden i've been
here for some times in the us and sweden
and switzerland is something you have
come some problem with
sweden
where is it
switzerland you see
okay that's a different all right
so sweden this is where i come from it's
a big country one of the biggest country
in europe this map is probably drawn by
swedish because it's actually bigger
than it is actually
but the thing is we have a
big country
from north to south to north
which means we have a lot of different
kind of climates in the country but
still we have a really good climate by
the way
uh even if we are very northern country
because we have the gold stream just go
by here and makes our climates better
than we actually should have so we have
a very mild climate and it's actually
very similar to new england when it
comes to the climate this new york new
hampshire connecticut vermont that's
kind of climate we actually have up
there
but we are much much northern and in new
england
uh
this is uh i've stole pictures and con
part here uh this is how it looks in the
south in southern sweden very
agriculture this is in the north a lot
of mountains and this is something in
between where i come from a lot of
forest this is actually a picture in the
midnight we have this thing i missed
here is the nights you have dark nights
in the summer we have very light nights
for two months we doesn't have any dark
nights we just have 24 hours daylight in
sweden which i prefer and this is how it
looks in it
so this is just an introduction to
sweden then you know you should go this
beautiful country
the campus this is the campus i come
from the swedish university of
agriculture science is a campus or it's
a university that are spread all over
the country we are
in the north in umu where the university
focus on forestry and fishing
we are up
also in uppsala
where is more agriculture an animal
type of
direction and in the south where i live
or where i work it's
more hot to culture landscape planning
that kind of direction so this is our
campus which is in a very in a very
urban area and the campus is like a
green island we have malmo in the back
this is luma and lund and you can see
how flat it is a very strong agriculture
and the campus is very old so
this is the arboretum which is the
biggest tree collection on the
collection of buddhist fish in northern
europe and have trees that are over 350
almost 400 years old it's a very big an
old
place and this is a castle in the middle
of the park and this is where i have my
office
so why i'm showing this is actually i
would like to invite you researcher
because we have something that we are
very proud of we have something called
the landscape laboratory
a thing that we are very unique in
we have a we allowed us to if we come up
with an idea try to design a woodland
for example a chinese or american or
just a nice design woodlands we allow us
to build it in scale one to one to see
how it works how it works over time
so in our campus we have a landscape
laboratory that is today 60 hectare
large and increasing every year with new
plantation where we're building things
just to see how it works in a full scale
and a good thing with landscape
laboratory that we don't have any end
date of the research
we can plan things and just following
for 10 15 50 100 years it doesn't matter
and so
the lack of the landscape laboratory
today is that we would like to have more
international researcher in
in the research group dealing with the
landscape laboratory you can see it's
some of the here
we're also working with wetlands storm
water management but also the research
field here belongs to the landscape
laboratory
this is like the blue grass lane but
much much bigger
and much cooler i think
sorry nina sorry pat all right
that was just an introduction but i will
do another introduction because the
research i'm doing together with nina
and company is where it's most of my
towards urban plants and special urban
trees
and special towards selection selection
of new species into urban environments
and in order to understand that i would
like to do just a short introduction of
how and why we're doing this
because international this is the
problem not only in sweden or
scandinavia but also here in the us but
all over the world there is a lack of
diversity when it comes to urban trees
this is a study we
finished a couple years back
where we evaluated the scandinavian
region when it comes to the diversity of
urban trees
and it's pretty scary numbers if you
have problems just talk with nina about
her in the inventory this weekend and
she'll now remember nowhere made
bernoulli maple but when it comes to
sweden it's limelight lime and lime
or in the scandinavian region but this
is pretty scary when you see that
almost 45 percent of all street trees in
helsinki the capital of finland it's
just one species of lion
linden okay linden lime we said yeah
linden then
sorry uh
but that's just the street trees health
secret haven't inventory other trees but
if you come to oslo the capital of
norway they have in their tree database
where which we use in order to do this
kind of evaluation
they also including public trees that
are in park environment but still you
can see even if you have street and
parking line it's just four three
species and stands for half of the whole
tree population
and this of course is not we talk about
sustainability and longevity and how
sustainable our urban environment is and
this is not
sustainable when you rely on very few
species in order to deliver in not only
the beautification of urban areas but
also as trees start to be more and more
important in order to deliver different
kind of ecosystem services for example
stormwater management
urban heat island mitigation
in sweden is a big thing we use trees in
order to have wind shelter in order to
reduce cooling down buildings which
increase the cost of heating up the
buildings and so on so tree is starting
to be very very important stuff in an
urban environment and if you just rely
on few species that's very risky things
in the same study we also evaluate to
see are there any differences between
different kind of urban habitats for
example street environment or park
environment and this is of course it's
not rocket science it's pretty common
sense that it is
easier to find a great catalogue of
species that grows well in park
environment because the park environment
they
have better growing condition compared
to a street environment so if you find a
few species that grow in street
environment well or perform rather well
you just go for them over and over again
so much of my research and together with
nina is towards street environments here
can you see there is less diversity
compared to park environment and this
just an example of an oslo
so much of the research we do in nina
is towards street environment because in
hard
surface landscape so to say is the need
of a great catalogue of great performing
trees
very very important to find
because in the paved environment the
need of trees is more important compared
to street environment because the few
trees that are allowed in the pearl
paved environment needs to deliver much
much more compared to trees just in park
environment because that's
easier for example stormwater management
and so on
so much of the research is towards
street environments
but i will continue because if you just
focus on few tree species this is what
can happen
this is
a nice picture of a less nice thing this
is the asian longhorn beetle
which is one of many threats to trees in
urban environments we just finished
studying a study which was published
earlier this year of
the
host range of trees that this bug or
asian longhorn bugs can can
attack and this is the result for the
asian longhorn beetle 137 species in
general
this is another bug
citrus longhorn beet is even worse this
is the one we have in europe
actually naturalized in italy moving
north and this is the big problem
so you see this map
few species
many diseases and insect attacks it's
not a good
calculation
so what we need is of course increase
the catalog species increase and also
start to using rare and untraditional
species species that don't get affected
of for example this one
but the problem is and this is another
problem for us
in a scandinavian country we are poor
extremely poor we we live actually one
of the poorest regions of the world when
it comes to native tree species here in
new york state you have disgusting rich
when it comes to native tree species
it's provocative to go out in the forest
here just to name drop all the trees
i'll just give you an example how poor
we are
this is the wooded horses it's like this
national symbol in sweden i'm very sad
that you
the story behind it is just very
ridiculous i don't tell you but this is
it's a native horse it's a wooden one
but each horse hairs it represents one
species or represent the species that we
have we have 30
34 native tree species in sweden 34.
so if you add diseases or insect attack
that attacking them now or will in a
short future attack the trees
we end up with this one
but if you also add urban pave size to
see which of these species this one that
can grow in this kind of habitats
which are
really challenging for trees
we end up with four tree species
so the thing for us scandinavian people
we can't rely on native only so we get
really provocative when we hear people
native only because we can't deliver
that in sweden i just want to make you
sure
so this is the result pretty pissed off
we get frustrating
how to do this so the challenge we are
doing or to stand in front of in
in sweden anyway is we have a lack of
diversity
we have many diseases
and also insect attack that attack in
our trees
and we have very few native tree species
so what we need is actually work with
more exotic tree species three species
that are reading from other parts of the
world but still grows in the climate
that are comparable to sweden that grows
well in sweden
but at the same time it's important
to find guidance
because you can't
be angry of on
landscape architecture tree planners
when they continue to use that
additional plant materials
because
think about it if you are a tree plant
and working on a very prestigious
project in the central new york city
you don't start to
use a very
rare or a plant material never used
before you don't do that
because if you do it you'll be very
famous for the guy that planted trees
that died half a year later you want to
work with safe materials
so as a researcher i see
it's our job to try to convince tree
planters to find evidence
of this rare and untraditional tree
species to find guidance for tree
planners in order to start to use them
because we can't force them we have to
find some kind of ground for them
so what we had done the last 10 years
is this
to traveling around the world to
actually studying
habitats natural habitats
which have clear similarities
to urban habitats
in sweden so these are just a few
examples this is from caucasus
is actually for chechnya
a place where i not recommend to go on a
vacation but they have fantastic
flora there and also climate which are
more than less identical to
in the city environment for example in
copenhagen or in stockholm
but also carpathian mountain in romania
i just showed this picture to nina
before you can see the bulb flowering do
you see that
it's kolchikum autumnale
a late flowering bulb one of the most
poisonous plants we know this is pretty
impressive that this horse is still
alive
and also us of course both west and east
and u.s
is areas
we studying a lot
so this is some of the parts of the
world we have been traveling around in
order to studying habitats and see which
other trees can we use but also try to
find evidence or guidance of how they
could be a good urban tree for us and
start to replace the one we're using too
much today or will get affected in a
short future
so you can see that the research is
really fun a lot of traveling but also a
lot of walking in mountains
so what we start with in the work is
start to do this kind of calculation so
we do different kind of calculation to
see which kind of areas of the world
have similarities to our not only our
climate but also trying to see which
kind of growing habitats can we
calculate to see similarities for
example this is from northeast romania
and the republic of moldavia where we're
trying to find just areas which have
similarities to paid environments in
copenhagen for example in a calculation
we try to add all the information or all
the factors that influence trees in paid
environment
and try to see where in other parts of
the world can we find more or less
exactly the same growing condition and
then we go there and try to find try to
understand it even more which kind of
species grows there and so on
i will i will explain a little further
so we start to just make an example of
one of these case studies this is from
the chingling mountain in china
where i've been several times and my
first year as a phd student i went here
for a whole year lived here and actually
i met a person from cornell here vinay
in this department so he's the one
actually introduced me to nina
and thanks to him i'm here today
probably
but the tingling mountain is an
interesting area for us in a way because
a recent collection from china is from
this area the cechon and yunnan area and
also the the eastern of tibet
which is probably the most specie-rich
region of the world
where you can find a fantastic
richness of species but the problem here
in this area the thing is not hard
enough for us in scandinavia
so many scandinavian went up here to the
manchuria area to the border to north
north korea and mongolia russia and
northeast china but the problem up here
the plants are too hardy the two
continental starts too early in the
spring grow too long in autumn and are
not good
actually they are better in northern
sweden than in the southern sweden
because they are too continental as i
said so some
so the area we are testing of course
we're traveling around in china to
collect to see which area actually could
be the best one and we ended up in
between in the chingling mountain china
if you like if you like panda bears this
is the place to go
and i will explain how panda bears are
one of the most hated animals for us to
collect plants
but i will explain later on
and it includes a lot of alcohol
but this area is actually it's not too
mild from this and the mountain is high
enough almost 4 000 above sea level
meter above sea level so still you can
find some of the elevation it's more or
less comparable to inner city
environment of the scandinavian area
so of course calculation to calculate
how good they are and then we go out in
the field to work
and if you believe field work is a
glamorous work
you're pretty wrong this is how it looks
this is in a farmer's house
i'm spooning with this is my driver
mr ma
and this is the students lyon leon
followed two two times and then he said
i'm never gonna follow you again because
it was a little bit too too high
mountain for walking so me and mr ma
were together for a whole year so i know
him very well very close
and this is the dinner every night
noodles and beers this is the candles
and the most important thing is to drink
beer so you sleep before mr ma because
when mr master to snore it's impossible
to sleep
but he missed the mice very nice guy
because when he drive over this kind of
bridges he asked me to step out and see
and then he drive over first a couple of
times and then you come and get me and
then we drive over so it's a it's a nice
guy
so this is how it is and this was
actually for a whole year mr ma and me
working in the in the chingling mountain
because the problem working in china is
that there is no good
literature not even for
chinese to to to read about the flora
system how the the different kind of
plants grows in different kind of
habitat different kind of elevations on
so the first two or three months was
just for me and mr ma traveling around
climbing up and down walking up and down
in order to start to learn how the flora
system are together and how different
species grow in different kinds of
habitats and so on which is a great job
but it's also frustrating when you have
a phd coming that you have to publish
papers all thing
but it's it's good fun
but this is how it works
in order to find we find an elevation
for in this case fifteen to two thousand
fifteen hundred to two thousand meter
above zero this is the place where the
climates are more or less
uh
exactly the same as in the city
environment of scandinavian but in order
to find the right habitats and right
growing condition the microclimate we
have to find it and that's found up here
on the warm south facing slope which
looked like this
so this that's why this is not the the
most nice place to go because you have
to tie yourself to a tree otherwise you
just
drop down here so it's that's why this
student stopped the work of just two
times the thing is this is how it works
and here you can find habitats that more
or less are have strong similarities to
to paved sites for example when it gets
warm and very dry especially after when
the snow melts or when after
a rain it dries up very quickly
which is
what it is in in paved environments
and this is the field work of course in
the morning two hours climb up here do
the work inventor in the tree take soil
sample drill the tree measuring the
trees all together gives you good
information of which species grow on
these sites and what the sites
represent but also you can see which
trees grows quick and with trees grows
very slow on these sites and that makes
you good information how to collect next
one how to collect the species that you
should because you're more interesting
in the trees that can tolerate this
growing condition but at the same time
grow quickly fast and delivering in a
rather short time skater anyway
because earlier
collection is just out collect seed
taken home and start to grow and it
takes two three generation of gardeners
because before you you start to learn
about the plants but by doing this you
can do a first screening in the field to
don't collect of the trees that don't
have the future as urban tree and focus
on the one that have the great potential
so this is the the work we have done
here in china
and
this is just an example of things that
we do in feed in order to communicate
with tree planners and also researcher
of the findings we do in field here we
have a slope it's a very sharp slope
this top of the
the ridge is just one meter so you go on
balance when you're walking here but
here you have a north facing slope
here's a south facing slope so the
distance from here to here
is just 20 meter that's it
but the species
combination between these slopes are
completely different on the south slope
we have plants that have the strategy
to
handle
warm and sometimes really really dry
conditions so here you find almost just
oaks
winter green oaks but also broadly oaks
and also two and one in needle pines
but on the south facing slope instead
here it's just more moist because after
a rain it dries up much slower
and it's not that warm so the
transpiration is less compared to the
south facing slope so the plants here
they are
very much needed to have moist and cool
condition but in the other hand they are
more shade tolerant
because they have to compete so the
restriction is not below ground
restrictions are above ground so these
trees are park trees that are very
successful in moist rich habitats and
also really good to compete in this kind
of empire environment
on this side restriction are not the
sunlight because there's a lot of
sunlight you can see the tree crown get
a lot of sunlight through but the
restriction is below ground and that's
how it is in urban condition for example
overpaid environment restrictions are
below ground not above ground
running water
sorry
so in this condition it seems like the
water is always running through the
slopes
because you know it's it's the trees are
on the sides of a mountain yeah so they
don't have stagnant water in this
country
but in
urban conditions if they're
usually irrigated
that's the design on planting pages
you're never ever
uh allowed to have standing water in the
planting pits that that's then then you
have done a wrong design of your
planting pits that's that's bad so you
should have well drained always also in
in in the in the planting pit as well so
drainage is is a key thing in urban
plantation anyway
so if it's watered down something wrong
that's not good
so
this is just an example uh
that you can see the difference between
different habitats but also when you go
out in the field you can see the use
potential of the trees when you are in
in natural habitats
and this is just some of the findings
china
is extremely rich in species many
species have never ever been grown in
our outside china for example this
almost cloud sessions eco
never been outside um
china and now it's in cultivation at in
all night but also we have shared to the
kew garden in in the uk just to be sure
that if our dies we still have some in a
queue and so on
this is a small leaf l you can see the
bark looks like the cell cover
and it grows really really well and fast
on this extremely dry habitats
and doesn't have any problem with the
dutch and the sea so suddenly
this is a good urban tree especially for
paid environments
but also you can find trees that
we know for a very exclusive parking lot
arboretum
but they have never go outside this
arboretum or botanical garden because we
don't know enough about them
but this habit of study gives more
information about them for example
exocordo geraldo de sistafilla holocarpa
i won't say an english name because i
have no idea what's the english name on
them
but these are available in arboretum but
through this habit of study we can start
to know more about it and start to use
them maybe in more public plantation and
so on so this kind of research is not
only to collect new things it's equally
important to find more information or
things that we have around us but we
don't dare to use because we don't know
enough about them
just a more example of this peonia so
froticosa this is the growing habitat
where it grows more rocky places
this is just two examples of
cordless tree growing hazel's this
cordless var jci with this peeling
orange bark and this is cordless
chinensis
which have a bark that looks dissimilar
to shag bark hickory it's two beautiful
trees that have never been in a more hot
culture perspective but they have the
potential to become very very good
horticulture trees
sorry are they nuts
yeah
and the correlations have very close
relationship with the
cordless columnar which is more common
in cultivation actually hybrids hybrid
days
together when they meet each other in
the central asia somewhere so the one
which are coalitions in cultivation
together
today is this hybrid so the true
correlations is not available in
cultivation today
because they don't have this bark this
beautiful bark
and also some early flowering trees
and also some late flowering trees for
example coral coralteria panucolata the
chinese tree that grows more or less on
bare rock one of the most drought
tolerance trees and the research me nina
doing here cornell which i'll hopefully
show you later on also show that it's so
so drought tolerant and it's this
perfect tree for the urban environments
special i just took this picture because
it's a
it's a big leaf the guy is 180 tall you
know
not really
another case study romania moldavia i
just want to go through here same thing
calculation about the habitats and why
romania and the eastern europe is one of
the most interesting area of the world
when it comes to climate smart trees for
urban environment is that we already
have a climate east of carpathian
mountains
this is europe sweden switzerland
we have the alps
we have the carpathian star shop here
and goes like this down this is
transylvania where the dracula lives
do you know that
but east of the mountains here
the west winds the moist winds from the
atlantic from the gulf stream more or
less ends here in transylvania
so the west part of the transylvania is
very wet very moist very rich big trees
big forest
but in the east
no much rain comes over the carpathian
so we have more or less as i said on the
east side the rocky mountains we have it
here very dry
cold winters cold and dry winters warm
and dry summers
so this area east of the carpathian here
but also down here in the caucasus
region have more or less exactly the
climate and growing condition as we find
in city in the city environment when we
add
urban heat island infections on so
that's why we have been a lot in eastern
europe to try to investigate trees
but the landscape is not that sexy this
is not the place you go when you visit
europe the first time it's better places
but this is how it looks this great huge
steps and the steps are mostly
famous for their meadows
this is the meadows this is a ukraine
ukraine zebra i just kidding this is
from a zoo in southern ukraine actually
now it's occupied by russia
where you can find some of the most
interesting meadows
uh of
of the step but just go through here you
can see how beautiful the step is when
it's flowering this is from romania
if you like perennial plants that could
be used for in roundabouts and or in
roof gardening and so on this is the
area to go because they are more or less
growing on the in that kind of habitats
but
in this step environment you also find
patches of forest
this very famous step forest of eastern
europe which includes many species and
this is how it looks when you do field
works i don't have mr ma with me and
here i'm alone
so this is the dinner in the field
it's a can ham
and when these cans of ham moves to
sweden they just change the label from
canned ham to cat food
because
because it it smell and taste probably
the same because that's that's the
dinner when you eat canned ham in a
romanian way
and i have a tip for you if you're
camping here don't throw apples
you haven't eaten outside a tent
because then the wild boar comes and the
wild boar here looked like the orcs in
the lord of the rings
and you don't want to have a couple of
wild boars fighting for your apples in
the middle of night i had that a couple
of times and that's scary it's very hard
to sleep after that kind of event
but that's how it is so you know it's
not that glamorous to do this kind of
research
but the thing is what you find here
it's some of the most interesting trees
for urban environments for example
service terminology that's the the one
growing here with these beautiful autumn
colors and the oaks here
are the quercus franet and the hungarian
oak which is one of the most drought
tolerant but also one of the most
beautiful oaks
for urban environments but also
silver linden
is that right
yeah tilia tormentosa which also
is one of the most drought tolerant
among the linden trees anyway
so you can see here some of the species
are in cultivation we have them we don't
use them so what we believe is in
through this habit of study we can find
more evidence to convince both nursery
to start to to produce them in higher
numbers and bigger trees but also
convince landscape architects and
planners to find or to start to use them
so it's not only to just grab new trees
but also
convince people to start to use them
but
one
thing when it comes to plant hunting and
trying to find good things is that you
don't have to find
new species you can equal find better
types of already introduced species so
the planting hunt the plant hunting days
are far from over when it comes to
finding really really good horticulture
plants i will give you a couple of
examples here
this is a solution of 100 years old
mystery i will tell you about you know
wilson ernest wilson rather famous plant
hunter he was actually hired in arnold
arboretum in boston for many many years
and but the first time he was in china
to collect he was collecting the
dovetree but the same trip he wrote in
his diary that
today i saw some beautiful flowering
magnolias one was red flowering and one
was white
i must come back in autumn to collect
them and he did he went back in autumn
collect the seeds from that but when
he's sending home to vege nursery
because they was paying for the trip
there
he he accidentally mix
both the seed in the same box and send
it home
and then nursery took them and started
to
propagate them and they grow fine and
after five or six years this nursery
have a sellout because the man of the
nurses said i'm fed up with it i'm gonna
sell this nursery
so at that time there was a six
plants from this magnolia collection and
that was selling to different parts of
england one at kew garden one at
bottomland garden and one at carl hayes
castle in
in
cornwall
and then they started flowering so the
one abortnet and kewguarding looked like
this
big beautiful flowers white with this
purple base
and get the name magnolia springeri
but they wanted car his castle
oops
it
have
red pinkish really dark pinkish flower
and the unique with this thing is that
you have a similar strong color both on
the outside of the temples as inside of
the temple that's very rare because when
magnolia's flowering they have strong
colors on the outside
but when they open up
they have less color and lose much of
the color when they start flowering
so this
dark colored and magnolia springer i
kept the colors even when it's flowering
out it gives much much more color and it
gave the name diva
the best name for this plant
and
people i get very excited over this diva
and have used in a lot you know the
different kind of crossings but when you
read wilson's diary he said a whole
valley of this diva this dark coloring
magnolias so for 100 years plant hunters
and stupid people like us have been
traveling to this area to try to find
this valley but haven't been successful
so instead people said oh just a myth
just a mutation
something wrong no no
but we thought
since i'm going to spend a whole year in
china
why don't
doesn't we do
a test to find this valley anyway we can
find some good moments but the problem
is this area is very rich in pandas this
cute little bit bear and the problem
with this bear is that if it shows up in
a forest the government
throw out the people in the forest and
protect a huge
piece of forest for this panda and it's
impossible for western people to come in
in this forest to studying because there
is this damn panda
so if you go to beijing to try to find
some
paper to get into this area
no chance instead you have to go to the
area and drink yourself into there
so what you do is try to go to the
proven city and find the boss there and
try to drink you up in a hierarchy
and this is after about eight days of
constant eating and drinking
and this is the
the
the forestry uh the highest boss on
there and the forestry in this area and
this is the man from the communist party
so these guys we was drinking with for
about two days and it's not like one
drink this is the morning drink it's
about 11 in the morning we have early
lunch and this is
and this is how it looks later in the
evening
this is my friend alan we we we tried to
drink even not every night we tried to
split the night between us and i think
this night was alan's night
so anyway
after
seven or eight days hard drinking this
is actually how you go in caucuses as
well so it's it's not only china but
after some hard drinking we get the
access into this area
and we start to interview people have
you seen this magnolia have you heard of
it and after some couple of days driving
we found this man
we find actually a tree
with this but as you see
it had it at his home
so we actually found the one we were
looking for the one would have a strong
color side on the inside of table the
side the same as
the outside of temple but still we would
like to find the wild population
of this
this species or this type of magnolia so
we continue to driving we have a small
bus
and we find a farmer that said yeah i
know a guy that probably knows more and
he and his family went into the van we
went to his place
and he said yeah but i know another guy
that knows a guy so after a while we
have like 20 people in a bus
crowded driving
and this is the place we ended up we
finally found a guy that yeah i know a
place go out the mountains take left
take right go up there take left
and this is the road
so actually we park the car down here
and walk up and when we go over a ridge
we start to see these ones
several are pink
clouds in the valleys
and when we get closer we saw these ones
even better than the diva is collecting
in the collection today
so this is just an example there is
more stuff out there so we actually are
reintroducing this diva that was
collected hundred years ago for from
wilson and now we have collecting at
least 40 new genotypes of these plants
and hopefully we get more genes into the
cultivation which we can do use for
hybridization and so on but also we have
found
this dark pink flowering manolas in
habitat which is much colder than the
one the growth before so it must
possible to find some good looking hardy
divas in the future
so just another example manuela biondi
a really boring magnolia
three centimeters large white with a
little purple base
and it's more
taxonomic interesting
but we thought it was interesting
because magnolia beyond is one of the
more hardest magnolias we thought we can
use it as an as a good parents in order
to find some hardy stuff
and
i was young then all right
i don't like this picture but this is
focus on this one okay
this is a big head
anyway uh
after a while when we start to to try to
find some i know la biondo we start to
see the variation within the species
and really quick we realized that the
most boring type
of the species is the one available in
cultivation today and the more
interesting types are still out there
and this is just an example of the
variation of the species magnolia beyond
the eye
so we go from this
rather big
seven to eight centimeter large
flowering plant flowering magnolias to
which have more like the tulip shape of
the flower to this bigger ones this
actually collected
behind um a house where they throw all
the rubbish there so actually the
working name on this is a white trash
this one
so it's going to be a very popular thing
here in the u.s we believe so we see but
you can see there are so much things out
there so the plant hunting today is
actually to find the better ones that
are in cultivation so in order to
introduce
rare or untraditional species it's
important to find
good looking types because some of the
types which are available when you go to
the kew garden or to arnold roberto
morris arboretum some of them are the
worst types
there's still much out there
just go through it albostonensis this is
the type you buy in the nursery in
holland this is how it looks in a while
see the difference
which i want to buy do you want to buy
tila tormentosa this is how
the species looks in cultivation good
tree but look how it grows
here
it's impossible to prune or do something
with even this one this is from the
plantation here installing silver it's a
good looking tree narrow tree crown but
look how it looks inside
this is a good tree for street
environments but impossible to have a
street environment because you have to
hire up the tree crown in order to get
buses or
try cars underneath
so what we did is spring we went down to
yash in northeast romania i don't know
if you read russian poems you do that
you should it's good stuff
josh is famous for its silver lines
silver linden sorry because if you read
russian poems they write beautiful
things of yashi yash and it's beautiful
avenues with silver linden and so on
yeah that's that's famous one so what we
did actually went down there for three
days to do it on smash and grab to find
some trees of silver limes that grows
more
as we want them as our urban trees so
what we find is this one would have a
central leader good tree archaic
architecture in a tree crown this is
another type
and this is another so this is the thing
we we do a lot of hunting to find better
types of trees
that could
in order to find better types they could
be more useful and start to uh
would you say start to
to be a good complement to the
traditional plant materials that we have
and um actually this was just a short
introduction what we're doing and what
we're doing now in uh here in uh
in cornell is actually another project
which is as a complement to this
actually to learn more about how
tolerable different species are we have
a project we call shut the hell up or
die
which actually is what is all about
trying to mapping how much a tree can
shut the hell up when it comes to dry
environment or wheat trees that can't
shut the hell up or die really early
because in sweden there are too many
landscape architects that want to have
magnolias in paved environment as a
street tree but we have to show that no
manola is not the good tree so what
we're doing now we're trying to find to
read the turbo loss point of trees in
order to see
how much drought they can take before
the cell structure in the leaves
actually destroys and magnolias destroys
very early which shows for the landscape
planners and landscape they are not
useful for pavement on the other hand
there are other species for example
eucomia or many oaks but also some of
the air maples
which have a very very high or low
turbulence point sorry very low turbo
loss point you can take very very high
drought without get damaged in the
leaves and it shows that these trees are
better suited
for urban pave sites so that's what
we're doing now so what we actually if a
general thing is trying to find
pieces in the past to show that this
species is better than that one and in
that case we can start to argue that
changing from the traditional plant
material to a more untraditional and
this work is not only to tree planners
but also towards nursery in order to
start to produce these untraditional
tree materials all right thank you
the ginkgos grow in sweden yeah kingdom
goes very well yeah
and gingko has started to be this
rare plants from
from an artery to become more and more
planted and that's part of the work we
have done to show that this is better
for example than the luxuries
yeah sure
are you successful in uh transferring
genetic material from china we were
talking about that
yeah
and if you did
how complicated the problem is smaller
disease
you have to have a collaboration
together with a university so they have
a very good collaboration together with
uh
university i think it's north west
university of agriculture and forestry
in china
together but we do it as a researcher we
don't do it as a commercial
so what we need is that we can collect
as a scientist it's possible for me to
collect planted in my research field and
see how it grows because in our research
we have four hectares of plantings of
chinese materials that we tested but in
order to commercialize it we have to go
back to china to to
get a contract with them
but it's impossible it's a waste of time
to get a contract before you know how it
will develop as an urban tree so you're
better to collect it as a scientist
because as a scientist i stand above
some of the laws it's okay for me to do
it but in order to commercialize it i
have to have purpose from china but then
you can go afterwards and it's possible
to get afterwards to get the right paper
in order to commercialize some of the
trees that we play
that's how it works the u.s is a good
country because you never sign anything
so it's very easy for me to come here
and collect in eastern europe alongside
the european union so that's even more
easier
the china is completely collected you
have to have collaboration with the
botanic garden or university otherwise
it's more or less impossible
i think we can take one more question
from ken and then i think we're out of
time
how many years do you have to grow these
typical trees before you can really
evaluate them yeah
well the first collection we did was
2003
uh
when i was just a research assistant i
had this boring job to take my backpack
and go to china and collect for the
professor that was my first job as a
researcher but already 2003 that's
10 years now or over 10 years you can we
already start
to to
propagate some of the materials around
that in order to test them how good they
are appropriate so you can see all
almost after
four to seven years you see the
potential of some of their blood
pressure then you can propagate them and
then we plot them
on
more places in sweden in order to
evaluate the hardness
and so on so
it doesn't have to take 60 or 70 or 100
years before you see
there's some of the problems that are
collected with nina here for example
some of the maples but also some of the
oats we can already see today after five
or six years they grow so well have been
taking so much to such a good
have grown so good during some of the
coldest winter we have for 50 years in
sweden they are so interesting so we're
gonna start the propaganda already now
after the six or seven years because
they have a good uh crown
hierarchy hurricane
with essentially everything so it's
but some of the trees shows their
potential much later some of them shows
early some languages it's different
it's a good answer
yes all right thank you so much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu